Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten
Mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff und ich begrüße alle zu einer weiteren Sendung, für die ich äh eine Reise angetreten habe. Es ist mal wieder Zeit für eine kleine Podcastreise auf der ich gleich mehrere Sendungen hintereinander aufnehmen möchte.
Mich hat die Reise geführt nach Teneriffa. Das ist auch ein sehr interessanter äh Ort für Raumfahrt und für die kosmische äh Forschung ist.
Heute möchten wir ein weiteres Mal das Thema der Exoplaneten, der Exo solaren Planeten aufgreifen. Das Thema hatten wir hier schon, ein paar Mal, vor,
sechs Jahren haben wir äh hier Heike Rauer gehört, die äh da einen Überblick gegeben hat. Jüngst waren die erdähnlichen Exo Planeten auch nochmal im Fokus, Raumzeit 96 mit Lena Nuak und natürlich auch die,
Folge 99 über äh Kiops, ein Satellit der in der Planet-Forschung auch zu neuen Erkenntnissen äh führen soll. So und,
Heute äh machen wir nochmal so,
Roundup, weil dieser Bereich sich natürlich extrem schnell entwickelt hat und ähm viele neue Erkenntnisse dazukommen und äh aus meiner Perspektive sinnvoll da auch nochmal einen größeren Blick drauf zu werfen,
Dafür begrüße ich zunächst einmal meinen Gesprächspartner heute nämlich Hansjörg Deeck. Hallo.
Ja guten Tag äh Tim.
Ja, herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit. Ich hab's schon gesagt, wir äh sitzen hier in Teneriffa. Du wohnst hier. Du bist hier auch schon sehr, sehr, sehr lange, ne?
28 Jahre.
20 Jahre und ähm bist hier.
Stationiert beim IAC, dem Instituto Astrophysiko de Canarias, habe ich richtig ausgesprochen, hervorragend. Genau und ähm ja vielleicht zu Beginn.
Ähm würde mich natürlich mal interessieren, wie's dazu kam, das so hier gestrandet bist überhaupt in dieses Themenfeld überhaupt in die Wissenschaft gekommen bist. Ähm was.
Ja, das war
eine lange Reise letztlich äh über mehrere Stationen erstmal zu mir selber. Ich bin in Bad Mergentheim im Norden von Baden-Württemberg aufgewachsen, habe die ersten Jahre im Studium dann in Würzburg, Physik studiert
und bin 1983 über ein Austauschprogramm nach New York State gekommen zu University of Buffalo,
äh wo ich äh dann zum Schluss,
bleiben wollte, weil mir das äh Studienumfeld besser gefallen hat. Die Professoren hatten bessere äh Kontakte zu den Studenten. Es war viel persönlicher alles und da habe ich dann letztlich einen Masters in in Physik gemacht,
der mir dann auch ermöglicht hat, nach äh Doktor
äh Studiengängen in den USA mich umzusehen. Äh da habe ich dann einen bekommen, einen Platz bekommen in Albaki in New Mexiko.
Wo ich dann äh sechs Jahre war,
und eine Doktorthesis gemacht habe, die aber in einem ganz anderen Feld war, nämlich das verwendet hat, was dort ist und dort ist das äh Very Large äh Rey, was äh nach wie vor das äh.
Eines der größten Radioteleskopes und habe eine Doktorarbeit gemacht über Galaxien äh und Radioobservationen und auch äh optische Beobachtungen über, weil wir ein kleines Teleskop auf dem Berg dort haben.
In meinem ersten Post ähm bin ich dann in Kontakt gekommen über einen Kollegen, der mich sehr beeinflusst hat.
Lorenz Stoy vom City Institut in in äh Kalifornien. Der war zu Besuch in Rochester, hat einen Vortrag gegeben und ich habe mich mit ihm unterhalten etwas und er hat mich eingeladen an einem Projekt
teilzunehmen, wo wir die sogenannten Transitz suchen. Damals, das war neunzehnhundertdreiundneunzig, war noch kein normaler Planet bekannt.
Und das war natürlich eine etwas weit hergeholte Sache mit sowas anzufangen. Aber als Nebenprojekt habe ich das dann angefangen. Wir haben einen äh Doppelstern äh angeschaut,
den heißt.
Und äh in einem Doppelstern wissen wir, ein veränderlicher Doppelstern oder äh ähm eine Clipsink Doppelstern, äh dass die diese Sterne in ein ein die äh die ähm Bahnebene mehr oder weniger zu uns äh ins
parallel zu unserem Blickfeld ist und man kann annehmen, wenn es um so einen äh Stern äh Doppelstern einen Planet gibt, einen sogenannten Zirkum, äh binären Planet,
um beide
beide äh Komponenten des Doppelsterns herumkreist, dass der wahrscheinlich auch in der mehr oder weniger in der gleichen Bahnebene liegt und deshalb Verdeckungen äh zu dem Bord-Doppelstern produziert. So haben wir angefangen neunzehnhundertdreiundneunzig
in einem Projekt, was er damals gestartet hat und hat versucht äh Mitarbeiter oder.
Oder äh weitere Kollegen zu finden, die ihm dabei helfen und ich habe ihn dann angefangen
äh von unserer kleinen lokalen Stirnware in äh New York State damals als erster Postock
Beobachtung von diesem Doppelstern aufzunehmen und gleichzeitig waren's sieben, acht beide Kollegen in Europa, in den USA und einer in Russland äh und in Korea auch mit dem gleichen Projekt beschäftigt.
Haben wir insgesamt letztendlich über 1000 Stunden Beobachtungszeit aufgenommen. Es ging über mehrere Jahre dieses Projekt und,
es war das erste Transitbeobachtungsprojekt überhaupt.
Wo wir diesen Stand genau beobachtet haben, dass letztlich keine keine Detektion gefunden hat, keine klare Detektion von einem äh Transit aber es hat äh die Limits gezeigt von der Methode, wenn man so einen Paper dann geschrieben, wo wir zeigen konnten, dass
Planeten, die größer wie zweieinhalb Adradien sind, um diesen Doppelstern nicht äh nicht wohl nicht existieren, ne.
War jetzt alles noch in den USA?
Das war zumindest der Anfang davon war in den USA 1993 fingen wir dies an.
Ich war nicht übermäßig glücklich in diesem ersten Postdoc und habe mich daher umgesehen nach anderen und
Dank eines Dia-Vortrags, die mir meinen Vater mal gezeigt hat über La Palma habe ich mich motiviert beim Instituto der Astrophysiker de Canarias einen Antrag zu stellen.
Und hatte Glück, dass äh der angenommen worden ist und so habe ich 1994 hier äh beim nennen das kurz IAC äh angefangen,
Äh und habe anfangs noch äh eigentlich das Thema meiner Doktorarbeit weitergemacht
äh was eben Galaxien waren und optische Beobachtungen
Aber dann passiert es eben, dass 1995 die erste Entdeckung eines Exoplanetens von äh äh bekanntgegeben worden ist. Der bekannte einundfünfzig äh Pack von ähm Michel Major und die Dicke los.
Und das hat natürlich enorm motiviert und in den nächsten
Jahren äh zwei, drei Jahren habe ich dann äh das die Exoplanetenforschung in mein Hauptthema verwandelt und die das andere Thema äh äh langsam zurückgeschraubt.
Weil das war spannend.
Das war spannend, da war was neu, da lief was, das war da die Presse sich interessiert für die Öffentlichkeit statt äh Radio Speck drin von Galaxien erklären zu müssen, wozu die gut sind.
Langweiliges Zeug.
Waren die Exoplaneten natürlich viel, viel interessanter, ja, ja.
Gut, ich meine, wenn man da noch so am Anfang äh der Karriere steht, dann ist es natürlich super, ne? Wenn man dann irgendwie was hat, äh wo man sich drauf stürzen kann. Genau, jetzt haben wir's äh auch noch mal betont, 1995 war die erste,
Bestätigung muss man ja sagen, eines Planeten, dass man sich sicher war, gesucht wurde ja schon lange danach. Mhm. Also das war ja in dem Sinne nichts Neues und so ein bisschen wie bei den Gravitationswellen.
Ist das so äh der Teil der ähm kosmischen Forschung, wo man sagt so, müsste es eigentlich geben? Wir sind uns ziemlich sicher, wir haben's bloß noch nicht gesehen. Irgendwann werden wir Erfolg haben, aber keiner kann genau sagen, wann's denn nun endlich soweit ist.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die Situation wirklich so war. Es gab schon auch Thesen, dass zum Beispiel unser Sonnensystem sehr
ein sehr seltenes äh System wäre. Äh.
Dass vielleicht nur einer zehntausend oder eine 100.000 Pfund Normalstern äh hätte und dass es daher vielleicht nur sehr sehr wenige Planeten hätte. War durchaus möglich. Äh er war keine
nicht die vorherrschende Thesis, aber es war eben wirklich vollkommen unbekannt, wie viele Planeten äh es ums um andere Sterne gibt oder welche Fraktion von Sternenplaneten haben, ne. War wirklich eine eine große Unbekannte
und äh es war ja dann auch die ersten Planeten waren eine Klasse von Planeten, die keiner erwartet hat, die sogenannten Hot Tschupiters.
Was eben äh große Jubetop-Planeten sind, Jupitergröße, Planeten, die in wenigen Tagen um den äh Zentralstand kreisen. War völlig unerwartet,
und da gibt es ja auch die Geschichte, dass äh Michelle, Major und die Delos haben ihre Daten ausgewertet währenddessen die Konkurrenzteame aus den USA,
äh die haben schon Jahre vorher gleiche Beobachtungen gemacht, aber haben nicht erwartet, dass so es so was gibt
und haben da ihre Daten eigentlich erstmal anlaufen lassen mehrere Jahre. Sie haben gedacht, sie müssten länger warten, bis sie Planeten mit mehreren Jahren oder einem Jahr Periode und längere.
Periodisches Signale zusammenbekommen und haben daher ihre Daten nicht ausgewertet. Wenn sie ihren ersten Teil ihrer Daten ausgewertet hätten,
schnell gesehen, dass sie auch äh ja Signale sehen von diesen Hot Jupiters, wo man eben mit ein paar Tagen,
paar Wochen Beobachtung schon ein klares Signal sieht äh und sie hätten wahrscheinlich vielleicht fünf Jahre vorher schon äh die gleiche Entdeckung bekanntgeben könnten, aber das war eben wirklich
äh dass sie überhaupt nicht in Betracht gezogen haben, dass es solche Planeten geben könnte.
Jetzt hast du schon so ein so ein Stichwort genannt, ähm damit kann man auch mal einsteigen, vielleicht diese ganzen Planetentypen, die jetzt,
quasi neu geboren werden. Wir sind halt extrem geprägt natürlich von unserem eigenen Sonnensystem. Ist noch gar nicht so lange her. Da war halt so generell so dieses ja, es könnte andere Planeten geben, aber wir wissen nicht wie viele. Grad so diese Frage der Einzigartigkeit,
äh des Sonnensystems, weil der Mensch lag ja bisher mit seiner Einzigartigkeit irgendwie immer ein bisschen daneben. Ähm jetzt geht's halt erstmal um die äh Planeten. Welche Arten,
Planeten unterscheidet man denn jetzt äh mittlerweile? Also das Beispiel mit dem ho,
Jupiter, ich weiß nicht warum der hot ist, aber die sind vor allem Gasriesen die aber extrem groß sind, also noch größer eigentlich sind.
Die sind ungefähr mehr als hat schon wieder heutzutage wird jeder, der ungefähr zwischen 0,siebenäh Jubiterradien und die Maximalgröße sind knapp
zwei. Das hat was zu tun mit der ähm internen Hydrodynamik, äh dass Planeten letztlich nicht größer werden können wie ungefähr.
Knapp zweiäh Jubiterradien und es gibt nur sehr wenige, die Größe wirklich wie eins Komma drei, 1, 4 Jubiterradien sind. Das sind dann meistens junge äh Systeme, die sich noch noch äh noch kontrahieren.
Wenn sie größer werden, werden sie auch langsam Sternkandidaten sozusagen.
Wenn sie größer werden, müssten sie in einem größeren Maße haben, aber es es gibt letztlich ein sogenanntes, das ist ein Plateau, wenn man die mit die immer mehr Masse rein zu zu addiert äh
es ein Plateau, das bei 1 Komma etwas äh Jubiterradien liegt und das geht von also einer
etwas unter einer Jubitermasse bis zu 70, 80 Jubitermaßen, wo man dann in der Tat schon von roten Zwergsternen sprechen.
Die ungefähr alle mehr oder weniger die gleiche Größe haben. Daher hilft die Größe von so einem äh Objekt auch nicht allzu viel, um sie zu klassifizieren,
Äh im Falle der Hot Jupiters nennt man sie Hot, weil sie eben in wenigen Tagen um den Zentralstern gehen und daher Temperaturen haben, die,
oberhalb von sieben, achthundert Kelvin liegen und bis zu knapp dreitausend äh.
Das liegt jetzt nicht an der Geschwindigkeit der Rotation, sondern an der Nähe.
An der Nähe zum Stern liegt das ja eindeutig ja ja
weitere Systeme, die interessant sind, die gefunden worden sind, sind ähm die die auch sehr verschieden zu unserem Sonnensystem sind, äh sind Systeme, die später gefunden worden sind äh von kleinen äh Planeten.
Auch relativ nah um den Zentralstirn.
Aber in der Regel nicht nur einer gefunden wird, sondern vier, fünf, sechs Planeten, die alle auf relativ nahe zueinander gelegenen Hobbits sind.
Und äh zum Teil auch manchmal.
Die Stabilität von denen etwas fragwürdig ist. Das sind die kompakten äh terrestrischen Systeme. Die wurden äh mit der Kepler-Mission später gefunden,
ja den 2tausendzehner, die sind wirklich äh verschieden.
Kennen dann einige sehr große äh oder sehr massive Planeten, wie die auch verschieden sind zu unserem Sonnensystem auf äh,
Perioden, die von wenigen Tagen bis zu einigen Jahren gehen könnten
Andere Planeten äh sind dann die einzige Klasse, die schon von 1995 bekannt war
äh sind die sogenannten Planeten, die äh um Pulsare-Kreisen, das heißt Sterne, die kollabiert sind, die schon ihre Supernova-Explosion hatten, äh äh oder Überreste von Sternen.
Wo auch nicht ganz klar ist, ob dieser Planeten wirklich Planeten sind, die es schon vor der Supernova-Explosion gab,
oder ob die sicherst später aus Überresten von den Sternen äh gebildet haben. Das ist nicht ganz sicher. Um's vielleicht etwas zusammenzufassen,
unser Sonnensystem gibt oder Sonnensystem ähnliche Systeme gibt es sicherlich,
in guter Menge, aber das Problem ist nach wie vor, dass dieses Systeme sehr schwer nachzuweisen sind. Bekannt sind im Moment um einige andere Sterne,
Planeten, die mehr oder weniger ähnlich sind wie unser Jupiter in Größe und auch in der Umlaufbahn, in der Umlaufdauer, beim Jupiter sind es elf Jahre,
und ähnlich könnte man sagen, sind vielleicht Umlaufdauer von fünf Jahre bis 15 oder 20 Jahre. Da gibt es mittlerweile einige
Detektionen. Das Problem ist allerdings, dass man dann nur diesen Jupiter kennt oder Jupiter ähnlichen Planeten, aber nicht die anderen.
An die kleineren Planeten in solchen Systemen ranzukommen, lässt es sich, das lässt sich fast nicht mit der sogenannten äh Methode machen.
Sondern da brauchen wir und die können wir noch erzählen, wenn wenn es.
Ich würde ähm gucken wir gleich noch drauf.
Wünscht ist, aber die brauchen die Transit-Nachweise.
Den kleineren Planeten und solche hat es bisher noch nicht wirklich äh haben sich finden lassen. Aber es gibt dazu Projekte über zu denen wir noch kommen werden.
Mhm. Also ähm um vielleicht mal so diese Planetentypen nochmal gehört äh zu haben, also der Hot Jupiter, dann hatten wir diese kleineren sind das ja.
Also die Steinplaneten also gilt denn generell diese grobe Unterscheidung mit, es gibt so diese Sternpaletten und es gibt die Gasplaneten, wie wir das bei uns im Sonnensystem ja so schön
auf Kreise, die existiert auch weiterhin, das sind im Prinzip die großen zwei Typen, die man erstmal unterscheiden muss und dann kommt's äh darauf an, wie nah sind die jeweils an der Sonne, was die Hitze betrifft eben dann natürlich die Größe et cetera.
Genau, genau. Äh das sind so die zwei wesentlichen Gruppen. Wir haben wir sagen typischerweise noch saturnähnliche Planeten. Das sind Gasplaneten, die so wie der Saturn und der Uranus so null Komma drei, 0,4 Jubiterradien groß sind.
Außer von denen, die auch
Gasplaneten letztlich sind, können wir die meisten Planeten relativ klar als äh als terrestrische Planeten, also äh solide Planeten äh klassifizieren oder als Gasplaneten wollen.
Großteil des Volumens zumindest äh aus Gas besteht,
Es gibt einige nicht so viele Fälle, wo wo die Dichte und die Größe etwas unklar ist. Äh gibt dann manchmal Hypothesen, dass die vielleicht hauptsächlich aus Flüssigkeit, aus Wasser oder äh aus was anderem bestehen.
Aber die allermeisten lassen sich klar klassifizieren,
und äh sehr interessant ist auch, dass die die Kurzperiodischen Planeten, die relativ nah an dem Zentralstand sind, da gibt es wirklich,
nur noch praktisch nur noch zwei Gruppen, die sind entweder,
terrestrische Planeten oder erheblich größer und jubiderähnliche Pläne. Es gibt nur sehr wenige zwischendrin äh und was wahrscheinlich passiert ist, dass die die äh,
Jupiter ähnlichen Planeten, dass die,
früher oder später verdampfen. Das Gas äh wird wird äh äh verdampft ja von dem Planet und er wird immer kleiner und zum Schluss bleibt eben noch der Kern übrig, der dann äh so ein bis zwei Erdradien groß ist.
Kurz periodisch sagen und von Jahren, also.
Mhm. Okay.
Meinen wir jetzt unsere Jahre im Sinne von wie wir sie äh beobachten oder Jahre im Sinne von was für diesem.
Wenn ich ja sage, beziehe ich mich immer auf ein,
und Kurzperiodisch ist für uns, äh sagen wir mal, unterhalb von zehn, 15 Tagen. Es hängt etwas am Stern ab. Ein ein massiver Stern ist natürlich heißer.
Und äh ein Planet vielleicht äh eine zwanzig, 30 Tagen wäre auch schon sehr, sehr heiß und damit kurz periodisch werden. Es sind um einen äh roten Zwergstern und einen sogenannten Emstern,
wer eine eine Periode mit 20 bis30 Tagen sogar in der sogenannten habitablen Zone, das heißt in der Zone, wo die Temperaturen äh angenehm sein könnten für für die Entwicklung von Leben auf dem Planeten.
Daher bei Emstern Kurzbayerische Planet einer mit fünf Tagen bis bis praktisch ein halber Tag war Periode.
Also der Merkur wäre selber gar kein Kurzperiodischer in dieser.
In der wer am Limit würde ich sagen ja na ja na ja.
Also wenn man.
Kennen keinerlei Merkur ähnlichen Planeten, weil die sind im Moment wirklich äh noch noch nicht detekt, die aber.
Weil die die Periode von groß um ja für Radialgeschwindigkeiten in Entdeckung ist der Merkur hat er zu geringe Maße.
Und äh um ihn mit Transit zu sehen, ist er schlichtweg zu klein vor der Sonne, äh kann im Moment nicht nicht nachgewiesen werden.
Okay, also es gibt.
Es gibt die Steinplaneten, es gibt die Gasplaneten, aber man hat jetzt, wenn man die Typen sozusagen sich mal so vorstellt, mehr also eine etwas größere Matrix, wo dann halt die anderen äh Faktoren mit reinkommen,
Nähe zu Sonne, die entsprechende äh Periode, wobei man wahrscheinlich generell davon ausgehen kann, umso näher dran an der Sonne, umso schneller äh läuft das Ding auch,
Nur, dass wir halt jetzt andere Geschwindigkeiten sehen, als wir es jetzt in unserer Skala hier,
gewohnt sind, sodass man fast glauben könnte, bei uns geht's relativ langsam äh zur Sache, aber wie das so insgesamt im Mittel äh ist, kann man glaube ich zu diesem Zeitpunkt auch noch gar nicht sagen, da fällt man wahrscheinlich noch nicht genug.
Ja, also ist eine der großen Unbekannten, ist wirklich äh nach wie vor die die typische Statistik von den Planeten,
um die sagen wir mal so einen ähnlichen Sterne,
Wir wissen heutzutage, dass äh ungefähr die Hälfte zumindest aller sonnenähnlichen Sterne wahrscheinlich Planeten hat
Es ist sind Hochrechnungen von von äh Beobachtungen über Transitz, aber diese Planeten sind typischerweise verschieden zu unserem Sonnensystem, wenn es wirklich sonnensystemähnliche
Planetensysteme,
wie, wie schon gesagt habe, kennen wir nur sehr wenige und äh der ihre, wir nennen das immer äh Bandens äh ähm,
äh Anzahl, Anzahl äh ist nach wie vor recht ungewiss.
Und auch die Vorstellung glaube ich.
Dieses äh Jahr, wenn man so ein Sonnensystem hat, dann ist es einfach sehr viel Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass so am Anfang kommen so ein paar Gestaltungsplaneten und dann kommen die ganzen bei denen, weil genauso ist es ja bei uns. Aber so diese Reihung, diese einfache Struktur findet sich jetzt auch so grade nicht oder.
Doch die findet sich äh,
äh es es wird immer so sein, dass zumindest die die Planeten, wenn die noch in der Position sind, wo sie sich gebildet haben am Anfang zusammen mit dem Stern in einem sogenannten bruttoplanetarischen äh Scheibe oder DISQ äh
da ist es immer so, dass äh innerhalb eines gewissen Limits äh äh die sich nur,
relativ nah am Stern sich nur äh Gesteinsplaneten äh terrestrische Planeten bilden können und weiter außen bilden sich die die Gasplaneten. Das ist also vorgeschrieben praktisch,
von der von der Entstehungsgeschichte und von den Temperaturen, die in verschiedenen Abständen vom vom Stern eben herrschen.
Was dann passieren kann und da passiert dann viel nach der originalen äh Bildung des Planetensystems ist, dass sich äh
Äh die Planetenposition ändern können. Das ist die sogenannte Migration und da gibt es viele Theorien dazu und insbesondere die sogenannten Hot Schuhe, dass die eben keiner erwartet hatten, hatte,
äh sind offensichtlich Fälle, wo wo ein Planet noch während der Bildung als noch die die Scheibe noch,
was existiert hatte, dass diese Planeten von außen nach innen eben äh migriert sind und in ihrer Position jetzt äh mit
Bahnen von wenigen Tagen, äh um den Stern und mit Oberflächentemperaturen von über 1tausend Grad eben, dass die jetzt dahin hingelangt sind. Da gibt es äh verschiedene Theorien dazu, wann das passiert und wann das nicht passiert
Und das hängt sehr wahrscheinlich davon ab, welche anderen Planeten sich noch gebildet haben. Zum Beispiel, wenn sich statt einem Jubiter in unserem Sonnensystem zwei oder drei mehr oder weniger in dieser Entfernung gebildet hätten,
mehr wahrscheinlich einer der innerste von denen, wer auch äh nahe zum Hauptstern äh migriert,
und hätte ihn bei diesem Weg dann wahrscheinlich auch die anderen Planeten aufgenommen, die kleineren Maßerde Venus,
und wir hätten auch ein sogenanntes Hot Dog. Das ist.
Warum warum fangen die an zu migrieren? Also ich hätte jetzt bis eben noch gedacht, da schlägt dann vielleicht irgendwas ein und dann ändert er die Bahn, das wäre ja sicherlich ein Ereignis.
Eine Einschläge sind's in der Regel. Meistens sind's äh wir nennen das immer ähm Wechsel oder Kapitänsbeziehung zwischen diesen ähm diesen äh anderen Planeten, die da auch sind und eben auch massiv sind.
Quasi so eine Aufschwingung.
Eine Aufschwingung, ja eine Wechselwirkung zwischen diesen und die Sache ist eben heute, wir können die Hot Jupiters relativ leicht nachweisen
Und da wissen wir wirklich ziemlich sicher, dass ungefähr ein halbes Prozent aller normalen Sterne äh einen sogenannten Hot Jupiter hat. Das heißt, die sind nicht allzu häufig, das wissen wir
Wir können aber in der Regel äh nur sehr selten die anderen Planeten nachweisen, weil die
Perioden haben von Jahrzehnten äh und länger und die lassen sich nur nur sehr schwer im Leben finden. Daher kennen wir nur den Hot Tube, aber nicht die anderen.
Okay, jetzt haben wir mal so einen kleinen äh Überblick äh bekommen. Im Prinzip gehören da ja auch noch so Begriffe wie Supererde rein, das ist ja äh das, was die Medien immer ganz gerne aufgreifen, weil das irgendwie so nach wie Erde nur noch noch toller klingt,
Aber das ist damit ja nicht gemeint, sondern das sind halt einfach äh im Prinzip von der Zusammensetzung her ebenso wie die Erde, sprich ein Steinplanet, aber eben etwas größer,
Mini-Nepune äh auch noch so ein Begriff, der Rumpf.
Das sind eben die äh die Gasplaneten, kleine Gasplaneten werden sich super erden, sind eben große terrestrische Planeten.
Ähm super sind die eigentlich nur in Größe. Man erwartet eher wenig, dass die äh wirklich sonderlich äh gut wären zum zum äh für für den für die Entstehung von Leben.
Aber ja gut, das ist eben eben jetzt.
Begriff ist in der Welt, den kriegen wir jetzt auch nicht mehr weg.
Ja den kriegen wir nicht mehr weg ja ja das ist natürlich also der Holy Grail ist nach wie vor äh äh Planeten zu finden, die wirklich ähnlich zu unserer Erde sind,
in Größe, in Oberflächentemperatur, in der Sorte vom Zentralstern,
äh das sind eben die, wo aber am ersten erwartet wird, dass sich Leben entwickeln könnte. Und das ist natürlich auch eine der großen Motivationen da in der Exoplanetenforschung.
Natürlich nochmal auf die schon jetzt immer wieder erwähnten Beobachtungsmethoden äh nochmal kommen. Die Transit Methode war die erste, war nicht die erste Methode.
Nein, die erste allerälteste ist, es gibt natürlich äh Versuche schon seit äh,
frühes frühes 20. Jahrhundert, ernsthaft äh exo Planeten zu finden.
Die älteste Methode, die ernsthaft versucht wurde, ist die sogenannte astrometrische Methode, wo man äh die Position von einem Stirn sich sehr genau anschaut.
Und schaut, ob der über die Jahre geringe, regelmäßige,
Schwingungen um diese Position macht und die wäre dann hervorgerufen durch eben den Umlauf eines massiven weiteren Planetens.
Diese Methode hat auch ähm ein paar historische falsche Entdeckungen hervorgerufen, die später widerrufen wurden und nie so richtig akzeptiert wurden.
Jetzt später neuere Entdeckungen mit dieser Methode gibt es aber jedenfalls historisch gibt's die Methode lang, aber hatte keinen Erfolg. Eine zweite,
Wichtige Methode ist dann die die Radialgeschwindigkeitenmethode.
Auch die Bewegung des Sternes durch den Planet beobachten, aber die Bewegung des Stirnes von uns,
und zu uns hin, womit das Licht von dem Stern etwas blau oder rot verschoben wird und das eben auch wieder durch den Einfluss des Planeten,
Äh das ist die Methode, die am Anfang den ersten großen Erfolg hatte mit dem einundfünfzig Pegasus und auch einem vorigen äh Planet, der sehr massiv ist, der nur damals nicht als Planet äh aner,
äh HD eins acht, ich komme nicht genau auf die Nummer jetzt. Äh war neunzehnhundertneunundachtzig, äh wenn der damalige,
Entdecker oder das Entdeckerteam, den als Planet äh ausgegeben hätte, werden Sie heute ganz klar die die ersten Entdecker eines bei mir, aber Sie ja waren damals zu vorsichtig und haben ihn als massive, wahrscheinlich als
als Zwergplanet oder Brauntwurf eben klassifiziert.
Jedenfalls ist diese Methode war am Anfang die wichtigste Methode, äh die die ersten, die Radialgeschwindigkeiten.
Okay, das äh können wir vielleicht nochmal vertiefen. Also.
Planet oder die Planeten ziehen um, um diesen Stern herum und wie das immer so ist, alles was Masse hat, zieht an, das heißt nicht nur äh die Sonne reißt an den Planeten, sondern auch die Planeten reißen an der Sonne.
Differenz, die das für den Stern ausmacht quasi in dem Moment, wo die Planeten mehr oder weniger.
Zwischen unserem Beobachtungspunkt und dem Stern hin und her gehen wird quasi der Stern mehr angezogen in diese Richtung und diese Frequenzverschiebung allein lässt sie schon messen.
Die lässt sich messen, die ist erstaunlich langsam zum Teil, also äh zum Beispiel die Erde auf die Sonne.
Wegen der Erde bewegt sich die Sonne mit einer Geschwindigkeit von zehn Zentimeter pro Sekunde. Von einem entfernten Beobachter weg oder zu ihm hin.
Sagen wir mal, jemand aus einem anderen Sternsystem schaut sich unser System an äh,
der Effekt der Erde wäre also eine Geschwindigkeit, die zehn Zentimeter pro Sekunde maximum hat und äh von Plus auf Minus innerhalb von einem Jahr sich verändern würde, ne
Sehr gering, aber es wird dran gearbeitet und es ist realistisch, diese Geschwindigkeiten beobachten zu können, also die die rot- und die Blauverschiebung des Lichts
durch eine Geschwindigkeit von nur zehn Zentimeter pro Sekunde. Das ist langsamer wie wie wir laufen, ne? Wir laufen ungefähr zehnmal schneller.
Das ist also erstaunlich, diese Präzision kann bald wohl gut erreicht werden im Moment werden äh
äh routinemäßig geschwindigkeiten von einem Meter pro Sekunde ähm gemessen. Das ist also die typische Spaziergänge.
Und damit können wir eben Planeten nachweisen, die vielleicht etwas schwerer wie die Erde sind, also,
unser Sonnensystem uns anschauen würden, müsste die Erde zehnmal schwerer sein, dann hätten wir diese Geschwindigkeit oder der Planet müsste näher am Stern sein und würde dann auch eine größere, sogenannte Radialgeschwindigkeit von dem Stern her ähm hervorrufen.
Das ist als eine Methode, die seit 1995 seit der Entdeckung des ersten Planeten.
Teleskopen wird das dann gemacht.
Diese Methode wurde verbessert mit mit Instrumentation, die immer äh raffinierter wurde,
die Originalentdeckung wurde mit einem relativ kleinen Teleskop in Frankreich gemacht von dem einundfünfzig Pegasus und äh wir haben hier zum Beispiel äh eines der besten Instrumente in La Palma.
Das ist äh das sogenannte Herbstinstrument.
Das haben äh ähm einem italienischen 3,6 Meter Teleskop äh installiert ist.
Ähm das kann eben mittlerweile diese Geschwindigkeiten, die ich vorhin gesagt erwähnt habe von unter einem Meter pro Sekunde schon messen.
Und das ist eins der zwei besten Instrumente im Moment, die die es gibt. Das Herbst hat noch einen Zwilling auf ähm praktisch identisch ist äh bei der E so in Chile,
Ähm und es gibt im Moment nur noch ein Instrument, das besser ist, das ist das sogenannte Heires Instrument, das am WLT auch in Chile montiert ist.
Ähnliche Präzision, aber es ist an einem acht Meter Teleskop statt an einem dreieinhalb Meter Teleskop installiert. Äh das ist im Moment das Empfindlichste Radialgeschwindigkeit,
äh ein Instrument. In der Zukunft wird's wohl dann äh am, äh dem äh vierzig Meter,
Extremi-Large Talascope, European-Large Talascope äh weitere Instrumente geben, die dann aber vor allem Sterne unter die nicht in der absoluten Präzision viel besser werden, weil da lässt sich nicht allzu viel machen
äh aber eben noch ähm mehr Signal bekommen äh hätten.
Um damit ähm schwächere Sterne anschauen können, weiter entfernt das Systeme. Ja, äh damit können wir dann natürlich mehr noch beobachten. Es gibt
bei der Radialgeschwindigkeitsmethode ein systematisch oder ein ein grundsätzliches Problem ist. Das ist, dass die Oberfläche der Sonne nicht nicht solide ist, sondern natürlich Gase sind und die bewegen sich mit Geschwindigkeiten, die viele Größenordnungen größer sind wie die Radialgeschwindigkeit,
und was wir beobachten ist die Radialgeschwindigkeit des Durchschnitts der Sonnenoberfläche.
Letztlich wenn wir uns die die was wir uns anschauen ist das Spektrum das so ne oder des Sternes.
Und das sind diese Spektrallinien eben. Äh und die sind natürlich durch die Oberflächenbewegung des Sternes äh,
haben die nicht keinen ganz genauen Wert, sondern äh in in Wellenlänge, die sind äh brodet. Die sind geweitet äh und damit ist es das Profil ist relativ weit äh,
sagen wir mal,
Kilometer pro Sekunde weit und wir müssen das Ding Durchschnitt ausrechnen davon auf eine Genauigkeit von Meter pro Sekunde. Daher ist die Beobachtungstechnik wichtig,
Äh es geht auch nur an manchen Sternen äh auf so so gute Präzisionen zu kommen, weil andere Sterne haben zum Beispiel äh viele Sonnen oder Sternenflecken, die stören praktisch das Signal und diesen Durchschnitt,
und damit kommen wir dann nicht äh so weit, dass wir da wirklich äh nach einigen Wochen oder Jahren von Beobachtungen wirklich eine klare Kurve sehen können, dass sich diese Radialgeschwindigkeit ändert, wie es erwartet wird von einem Planeten.
Okay, also die Radialmethode Steine am Anfang war verantwortlich für die ersten wirklich bestätigten Entdeckungen und,
verbessert sich auch noch. Die ist jetzt sozusagen nicht raus. Man nutzt die einfach weiter, andere Methoden gibt es, aber die äh wird auch bleiben und wird immer besser, umso besser die Spektographen werden die Teleskope werden
man auf diese Sterne beziehungsweise in dem Fall auf diese Planeten äh ansetzen. In dem Fall sind's ja wirklich die Sterne, auf die man äh.
War eigentlich praktisch immer nur den Stern und nicht den Planeten.
Ich ich komme vielleicht noch zu noch zu einem aber jetzt hört man wahrscheinlich die Transitmethode äh erläutern, ne.
Auf jeden Fall.
Äh das ist heute vielleicht die wichtigste Methode, die wir auch wie gesagt ich habe schon gesagt, ich habe ein Projekt angefangen mit der Transit-Methode, bevor der erste Planet gefunden wurde neunzehnhundertfünfundneunzig,
die wurde auch schon lang erwartet diese Methode. Die wurde in den 70er Jahren schon vorgeschlagen äh aber dann wirklich umgesetzt erst äh wie gesagt in den Neunzigern.
Äh bei dieser Methode, die ist konzeptuell äh die einfachste, äh was wir beobachten, ist letztlich, äh dass das ein Planet vor einem Stirn vorbei
geht auf seinem seinem Orbit
und den Stern etwas verdunkelt einen kleinen Teil von dem Stern, der stand da mit etwas dunkler wird und ähm und eben das wird gemessen mit einem Fotometer, das für einige Stunden zum Beispiel der Stirn,
Sag mir mal ein Prozent äh dunkler wurde äh und dass sich das wiederholt nach einigen Tagen und wenn man das beobachten
äh und uns sicher sind, dass wir hier keine keine Messfehler haben, dann können wir daraus schließen, dass da ein kleineres Objekt um den Stern herumkreist und ähm dass es eben wohl wahrscheinlich jetzt heutzutage wird es relativ schnell akzeptiert vor
30 Jahren äh war das anders. Knapp 30 Jahren, äh dass es sich dabei um ein ein äh sogenannten Hot Upiter Planeten handelt.
Es geht also wirklich nur drum, eine periodische Verdunkelung, leichte Verdunklung des Sternes zu beobachten.
Wirklich der erste Planet, wo wir dann wirklich auch sicher waren, dass es ein Planet ist und nicht was anderes. Die mit der Radialgeschwindigkeit äh gefunden wurden.
Als das herauskamen. 1995 gab es durchaus auch ernsthafte ähm bekannte Forscher, die äh zumindest,
sicher waren und nicht wirklich akzeptiert haben, war als die erste der erste Planet.
Sowohl mit der Radialgeschwindigkeitsmethode als auch mit Transitz äh gefunden wurde. Das war neunzehnhundert neunundneunzig.
HD zwei null neun vier fünf acht.
Da war dann wirklich klar, Exoplaneten gibt es wirklich. Das wurde dann wirklich universell auch akzeptiert, dass auch die anderen Planeten, die vorher mit der Radialgeschwindigkeitsmethode gefunden wurden, dass das eben auch äh wohl höchstwahrscheinlich Planeten sind.
Transitmethode setzt er im Prinzip voraus, dass der Planet äh auf der Sichtachse zwischen Erde und ähm,
dem Stern durchgeht. Mit anderen Worten, man kann mit dieser Methode ja im Prinzip nur einen Bruchteil aller Planeten überhaupt entdecken.
Das ist so ein bisschen.
Ja, genau. Das ist eben der Nachteil der Transitmethode, dass äh die Wahrscheinlichkeit äh äh einen Planeten zu entdecken ähm.
Relativ klein ist, sagen wir's mal so, von einem zufällig ausgerichteten Planetensystem, wenn es die Radialgeschwindigkeitsmethode kann fast alle Systeme,
finden, außer die, wo wirklich äh wir wir senkrecht auf den Orbit draufschauen. Die tun keine Radialgeschwindigkeit hervorrufen. Das ist eben ein ein großer Unterschied äh,
zwischen diesen beiden Methoden. Eine Sache, die allerdings wiederum glücklich ist,
wenn wir einen Planeten mit der Transitmethode finden, ist die Bahn so ausgerichtet eben, ja, wir schauen auf äh praktisch äh in die Ebene der der Bahn hinein,
parallel zur Ebene, zur Bahnebene, dass auch äh dieser Planet gleichzeitig für die Radialgeschwindigkeitsmethode optimal ausgerichtet ist und mir das optimale Signal bekommen.
Aber wie immer bei der Transitmethode, wir.
Haben eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit einen Planeten mit einer mit einer gegebenen Größe und gegebenem Abstand vom Stirn zu finden und äh daher müssen wir immer dann hochrechnen, wenn so und so viele,
Planeten bei der Transitmethode mit der und der Größe und und und Umlaufdauer gefunden werden, was können wir daraus überhaupt das Vorhandensein von Planeten, von dieser Sorte insgesamt äh aussagen. Das muss dann hochgerechnet werden, weil wir eben immer nur einen kleinen Bruchteil der der.
Aber im Prinzip müssten sich ja mit der Radialmethode alle Transitbeobachtungen bestätigen lassen.
So ist es theoretisch und so wurde es auch lang gehandhabt bei den ersten Transitbeobachtungen wurde dann auch immer gleich zum,
nach äh Radialgeschwindigkeitsbeobachtungen gefragt und es ist nach wie vor der Fall. Zum einen zum Nachweisen ist der Planet wirklich ein Planet ist und nicht zum Beispiel ein bedingungsveränderlicher, wo ein kleiner.
Stern, der oft ähnliche Größe wie Jupiter hat äh vorbeigeht, ähm der vielleicht ähnliche Signale hervorruft,
bei der Transitminute gibt's auch ein Problem oft, dass wir einen Vordergrundstern haben.
Und sehr nahe daneben, aber in Wirklichkeit viel weiter entfernt, ist ein Bier.
Und dieser Bedeckungsveränderlicher. Er hat eben seine seine Klipsen
und wir sehen aber nur den den Flux von den drei Sternen letztlich zusammen und und es erscheint wie ein ein Transit. Daher.
Ist es oft nicht ganz einfach zu entscheiden, ob ein ein Transither, der nur optisch gefunden wurde, ist eben, ob's wirklich ein Planet ist.
Daher wird heute auch nach wie vor routinemäßig werden werden, zumindest die interessanten äh Transitkandidaten mit Radialgeschwindigkeit äh beobachtet.
Eben zum Nachweis, aber zum anderen auch, ist es wichtig, weil über die Transitmethode, was wir da finden, ist die Größe des Planets oder die Größe des Planets relativ zum Stern. Mit der Radialgeschwindigkeitsmethode finden wir die Masse des Planets relativ zum Stirn.
Und wenn wir natürlich das mit beiden beobachten können, mit beiden Methoden, dann können wir auch die Dichte ab äh ausrechnen von dem Planet und wir haben damit die die best bekanntesten äh Planetensysteme. Daher wird nach wie vor Radialgeschwindigkeit,
wenn's sinnvoll ist jedenfalls fast immer auch äh,
verwendet, um um Transitkandidaten äh nachzuverfolgen. Das ist was, was wir in der Aktualität auch äh sehr viel machen jetzt grad.
Überhaupt entwickelt sich ja, glaube ich, die Disziplin so langsam von ähm.
Wir suchen jetzt überhaupt erstmal welche, wolltest sicher sein, dass es die gibt. Wir bestimmen mal Bahnenumlaufzeiten äh et cetera, dann eben die Planeten. Typen ähm wollen auch immer kleinere ähm,
und immer weiter entferntere Planeten äh finden, was ja im wesentlich mit Auflösung und Zeit äh zu tun hat hinzu, wir wollen jetzt aber auch mehr konkret über die Planeten selber,
Wissen, also da nochmal schauen, aber ähm.
Eigentlich neben der Radialmethode, Transitmethode noch eine weitere Methode äh erwähnen, die jetzt noch eine Bedeutung hat, die das Feld noch ergänz.
Er wäre vielleicht noch eine, weil das ist eigentlich so die die einfachste. Äh,
Das ist äh wir nennen's immer direkt Imaging oder so ein Bild aufzunehmen,
mit einem Teleskop mit hoher optischer Auflösung ein System anzuschauen und das sehen wir dann vielleicht in Zentralstern und vielleicht sehen wir in geringer Entfernung davon ein weiteres Objekt, das möglicherweise ein Planet ist.
Wenn man das dann zum Beispiel ein Jahr oder zwei Jahre später wieder beobachtet, sieht man, dass sich dieses kleine Objekt um den um den Stern herumbewegt. Ähm.
Das ist natürlich die die einfachste Methode konzeptuell in der Praxis äh lassen sich auf mit dieser Methode allerdings nur Planeten nachweisen, die relativ weit entfernt sind vom Stern oder
Problem ist der enorme Unterschied in der Helligkeit zwischen Stern und einem Planet, weil ein Planet tut nur das Licht vom vom Stern reflektieren.
Und was in der Praxis gefunden wird, sind äh Planeten, die sich noch bilden
die selber noch eine gewisse Temperatur haben, wo sich das Gas noch zusammenzieht und die noch die die Kontraktionswärme haben,
und damit wurden einige Systeme gefunden eben, die relativ jung sind, wo der Planet auch noch eine Größe hat, die die größer ist wie die, wo er mal später durch die durch den Hauptteil seines Lebens haben wird.
Und ähm.
Ja, das sind Systeme, die typischerweise Planeten haben, die erheblich weiter weg sind wie Jupiter, also zehn, 20, dreißig, äh astronomische Einheiten.
Denke ich, ist noch die wichtigste Methode außerhalb denen, die wir die wir bisher erwähnt haben. Äh für gewisse Systeme gibt's dann auch noch auch noch ähm da kommen wir vielleicht noch dazu mit einem Planeten. Da wird auch noch das sogenannte Timing gemacht.
Aber ich denke unter dem den Methoden, die die für normale Planetensysteme äh äh üblich sind oder bekannt sind, sind sind es die wichtigsten, die wir jetzt erwähnt haben.
Die Entstehung eines äh Solarsystems,
am Anfang muss ich erstmal aus dem Staub der Stern äh formieren, die Rotationen,
dieses gesamten äh Staubs fließt ähm in die entsprechenden Rotationszeiten eines solchen Sterns ein. All der Staub, der nicht eingefangen wird, aus dem bilden sich diesen Planeten. Das heißt, man hat dann diese.
Planetare äh Scheibe quasi, die dann vielleicht, wenn man direkt daneben steht, so ein bisschen ähnlich aussieht wie die Ringe halt beim Saturn, aber halt noch sehr viel weiter ausgedehnt. Sprich,
Ist ja jetzt nicht so ein,
Ding so Stern und dann ploppt, dann sind da irgendwie so Planeten, sondern das ist ja dann auch so eine Evolution dahin äh über Millionen von Jahren. Kann man denn mit einer dieser Methoden oder mit der Kombination dieser Methoden auch
Sternsystem befinden, wo quasi die Planeten noch gar nicht fertig sind, sondern
kann man auch äh da schon erkennen, so aha okay, da bildet sich gerade was heraus.
Ja, da ist eben gerade die Methode, die ich jetzt als letztes erwähnt habe, das das direkt Imaging.
Ist da wichtig, weil in dieser Methode äh sehen wir zum einen oft den Planet, aber wir sehen auch noch die Scheibe, in der der
Gasscheibe oder Staubscheibe, in der der Planet eben drin ist, die können äh auch gesehen werden und es gibt auch viele Fälle, wo man eben nur diese Scheibe sieht, aber keinen Planeten drin, weil diese Scheiben sind relativ leicht nachweisbar, die haben eine gewisse Temperatur,
von einigen zig Grad Kelvin und die können dem Infraroten relativ leicht äh gefunden werden. Also
mit dieser Methode eben können wir sehr viel über die Entstehungsgeschichte eben nachweisen und man sieht zum Beispiel auch Gipfel äh wo man sieht, dass diese diese Schaden eine gewisse Struktur haben. Das sind mehrere Ringe dann letztlich, wo sich dann wohl entsprechende Planeten äh drin bilden.
Grad Kelvin klingt jetzt nicht besonders warm.
Also relativ kalt, ja ja genau. Aber eben im Infraroten äh können diese diese diese thermische Strahlung von von solchen Temperaturen eben nachgewiesen werden.
Genau, kann nachgewiesen werden und jetzt hatten wir als Beispiel bisher eigentlich nur die Bodenteleskope, aber es sind ja vor allem die Weltraumteleskope, die jetzt die größeren Entdeckungen in den letzten Jahren,
festgemacht haben. Du warst ja auch ähm.
Beteiligt an der äh Entwicklung und natürlich auch an der Nutzung zahlreicher Teleskope, welche Teleskope haben wir jetzt den größten Impact äh gehabt und woran warst du beteiligt?
Also äh.
Beteiligt war. Ich hab's ein bisschen historisch äh zu machen äh an der Corodmission, wo ich die spanische Exoplanetenbeteiligung ähm.
Ähm geführt habe. Äh war der erste Satellit, der wirklich äh spezifisch für Excel Planeten entwickelt wurde.
Also zweitausendsechs gestartet bis zwanzig zwölf glaube ich äh nutzbar gewesen.
Ja äh der hat äh im Moment sind 37 Planeten mit Transitz gefunden.
Relativ wenig und wenn man sich die heutigen Zahlen anschaut.
Das bekannteste, was er fand, war der erste wirklich terrestrische Planet, wo man wirklich 100 Prozent sicher ist, dass Terest frisch von der Größe
der auch mit danach nachgewiesen wurde, wo man wirklich sagt und ja, der restrische Planeten existieren, um andere Sternensysteme herum,
Dann die Mission, die wohl bis heute den größten Einfluss hatte, äh ist die Kepler-Mission, die amerikanische Kepler-Mission, die wurde 2008 gestartet und lief bis 2013 wurde ein technischer Defekt, sie sie äh,
zumindest äh die Hauptmission beendet hatte.
Äh auch mit Transitz beobachtet äh größere Felder mit einem größeren Teleskop in einem Meter Teleskop. Hatte nur einen dreißig Zentimeter Teleskop.
Und die hat ähm fünf Jahre lang das gleiche Feld beobachtet mit zehn bei zehn Grad Größe ähund hat
über 3.000 Planeten gefunden und auch darunter eine sehr große Menge an Planetensystemen eben, seitdem weiß man auch wirklich mehr oder weniger gut die Statistik, äh zumindest von den Planeten in der Größe, die Kepler eben beobachten konnte, entdecken konnte.
Lief ja noch ein bisschen länger, aber war technisch eingeschränkt und.
Technisch eingeschränkt äh bei Caplers sind die sogenannten äh Gyroskope ähZweig ausgefallen, die die Ausrichtung stabilisieren und es gab dann so eine Art
Notmodus wurde erfunden dann wirklich äh ähm ziemlich äh kurzfristig.
Dass Kepler zumindest in der in der äkypischen Ebene, also eine Ebene vom von der Erdumlaufbahn über die Sonne,
noch ganz gut beobachten kann und da wurde dann eine eine zweite Mission, die so eine K2-Mission noch noch ähm ähm.
Durchgeführt, die über mehrere Jahre lief, wo dann Felder, mehrere Felder beobachtet wurden über kürzere Zeit, spannend und auch mit etwas äh geringerer Präzision und die haben zumindest die Statistik auch nochmal äh weitergebracht.
Eine weitere wichtige Mission, die jetzt seit hm drei oder vier Jahren äh läuft, ist die Testmission.
Die es auch äh transit, also wie gesagt, alle alle,
Exoplanetenmissionen, die bisher ähm gestartet worden sind, äh sind auf Transit äh Beobachtungen äh ausgerichtet. Der Grund ist einfach der, dass der der Gewinn,
gegenüber Erdbeobachtungen da besonders Großes. Äh auf der Erde sind wir immer beschränkt von dem Tag-Nacht-Rhythmus. Wir können nur nachts beobachten. Wir haben oft schlechtes Wetter.
Äh wenn es eine eine eine Mission im All natürlich 24 Stunden äh beobachten kann und nie für irgendwelche Probleme mit Wetter hatte, sind erheblich bessere Daten, die da eben kommen, präziser, besser charakterisierbar.
Aber wäre es nicht auch möglich eine Mission zu machen, die sowohl äh macht als auch Transitmethode gleichzeitig.
Theoretisch ja, aber Lady Vilosity, also Rad ähm Spektroskopie bringt relativ wenig ins All zu gehen. Bei Radio Villoity, was wir brauchen sind äh Spektren, die einen gewissen Abstand genommen werden
ne? Das hängt von der Orbit ne von der Orbitalperiode ab, an der mich interessiert sind, aber sagen wir mal zehn Mal pro Orbitalperiode. Wir können mehrere Perioden dafür verwenden.
Das Wetter ist auch nicht so wichtig, solange es nicht wirklich schlecht ist, äh ist das in einem Spektrum nicht so wesentlich. Daher bringt es wenig äh ein Spektograph äh.
Der Sorte ins ins All zu schicken, ja.
Deswegen konzentrieren sich jetzt alle auf Transit.
Es gibt eine Spektrographenmission, die ist ähm von der ESA
geplant. Mal zum einen ist das James Web, das jetzt gestartet worden ist vor kurzem und und die sogenannte Arienmission von der ESA, die für 2029 zum Start geplant ist.
Ariel wird äh Spektroskopie machen, wenn dransitzt, passieren. Das ist der ihre Hauptmission. Das ist ein Problem äh da kommen wir vielleicht noch dazu. Es ist interessant ähm.
Zumindest größere Planeten zu beobachten, wenn sie Transitz machen, weil wir dann äh.
Blick in die Atmosphäre.
Blick in die Atmosphäre von von dem Planet bekommen.
Mhm. Da wollte ich da wollte ich äh ohnehin noch drauf zu äh sprechen kommen. Also äh vielleicht nochmal kurz zu den Missionen, weil äh in der letzten Sendung mit mit Heike Grauer habe ich ja auch schon auf auf zurückgeblickt, nur Test ist ja neu gewesen.
Ist neu, ja, das gab's.
Äh da stand dann sozusagen schon am Horizont, aber ähm,
Stand also, stand noch nicht am Häusern, sondern war nur am Horizont und ähm was verbessert den Test gegenüber Capler, was was sind denn da so die die nächsten Schritte, die da gegangen werden können?
Also Tess ist eine Mission. Ich denke es war 2tausendachtzehn, dass die äh wirklich gestartet wurde.
Die tut den ganzen äh ganzen Himmel beobachten, ähm mehr oder weniger gleichmäßig.
Äh und ist damit in der Lage, die erste.
Katalogisierung von Transe, die macht auch Transitz äh aber die erste komplette mehr oder weniger auch homogene äh Katalogisierung von von dem Transitsystem äh zu machen.
Test ist relativ klein. Äh das heißt, es kann nur eine Transitz finden, um relativ helle Sterne.
Und äh beobachtet auch seine Felder für nicht allzu lange, 28 Tage beobachtet in der Regel seine Fälle, damit sehen wir nur äh wiederholte Transitz von Systemen eben, die Perioden haben von weniger wie 28 Tage,
Er hat daher seine seine Limitationen aber ich ich denke es sind zwei Sachen, die die bei Tess,
als Ergebnisse wichtig sind. Zum einen eben, dass wir wirklich,
bessere Aussagen machen können und da denke ich fehlt auch noch einiges an Forschung und und dass das äh wirklich
integriert wird die ganzen Ergebnisse, wie verändern sich die Planeten in der und der und der Richtung äh von uns aus gesehen in der galaktischen Ebene oder bei der oberhalb,
zum galaktischen Zentrum hin, vom galaktischen Zentrum weg. Äh da können sicher noch viele Studien gemacht werden, wenn Tes einigermaßen komplett ist.
Und die anderen Ergebnisse grotesk äh wichtig sein wird äh sind das Tests relativ helle Systeme oder relativ nahe Systeme äh beobachtet.
Das ist letztlich kommt es von seiner Limitation, dass Test relativ klein ist, die Teleskope haben zehn Zentimeter Durchmesser.
Sind vier Stück davon. Daher die Systeme wo Tests findet.
Lassen sich äh weiter beobachten mit anderen Instrumenten äh typischerweise Spektroskopie zum Beispiel, was wir vorhin schon mal angerissen haben.
Oder auch mit mit großen Teleskopen für Transitz, wo man vielleicht mehrere,
ähm Wellenlängen beobachten können. Jedenfalls sind die gut geeignet für weiterführende Studien,
und dafür Radio natürlich sind das relativ einfache Objekte in der Regel,
Daher finden wir über Tests, bei Testentdeckungen relativ viele Systeme, die sich gut charakterisieren lassen. Das war ein Hauptproblem mit Kepler. Kepler waren ein Meter Teleskop
die typischen ähm Systeme, die findet, waren 14. oder 15te Magnet und die meisten davon äh sind daher zu lichtschwach, um wirklich diese hochpräzise ähm äh Spekt
Kopie zu machen. Wir brauchen für die Radialgeschwindigkeit. Daher war
Die meisten Kepler kann äh Systeme konnten nicht mit Radialgeschwindigkeiten nachbeobachtet werden. Wenn es bei Test kann das bei praktisch allen gemacht.
Ist ein ein großer Vorteil von von Tests.
Also im Prinzip während die ersten Missionen alle noch drauf waren wir wollen jetzt überhaupt erstmal was finden, was wir auch bestätigen können,
mit Tessol ein bisschen die Phase eingeleitet. So, okay, wir wissen, das gibt's. Äh wir haben die und die Häufigkeit. Wir wissen jetzt, mit welcher Präzision wir jetzt eigentlich ins All schauen müssen und jetzt geht's erstmal dadrum, zu katalogisieren, möglichst einen Überblick.
Zu gewinnen, wo man dann mit anderen Missionen oder mit anderen äh Testgruppen, die schon existieren, äh nochmal genauer hinschauen kann, um überhaupt erstmal was zu haben. So wie,
zum Beispiel jetzt irgendwie einen neuen Sternenkatalog macht, wo sich alle drauf stürzen, weil sie viele neue Erkenntnisse, also schon mal für alle ähm neuen Erkenntnisse Ansatzpunkte haben, liefert Test jetzt vor allem viele neue Ansatz.
Ja in dem Sinn sollte ich vielleicht jetzt auch die Pladomission noch noch erwähnen, ne? Äh
die Heike Rauer vor sechs Jahren schon mal äh wohl äh vorgestellt hat. Äh Heike Rauer ist ist die äh ähm,
Haupthauptinvestigator von von Plato.
Und diese Mission äh wird die nächste große Mission sein, die auf Exce Planeten ausgerichtet ist, ähm Plato macht auch Transitz, wie wie die bisher benannten.
Wird es eine ESA-Mission, europäische Raumfahrtagentur und ist für Anfang 2027 ist der Start geplant. Äh,
ganz grundsätzliches ähnlich, sagen wir mal wie Käppler, wird aber ein erheblich weiteres Feld beobachten, statt zehn mal zehn wird Plato äh fünfunddreißig mal dreißig5 Grad äh großes Feld beobachten.
Also ähnlich insofern ist das man sich einfach auf einen einzigen Fleck quasi konzentriert und da die ganze Zeit hinstarrt.
Ja, zumindest äh bei Plato ist im Moment vorgesehen, dass es zwei Felder gibt, die jedes äh ungefähr zwei Jahre beobachtet werden. Wobei da gibt es noch einige Diskussionen, was, wie Ivi wirklich der das Beobachtungsprogramm aufgebaut wird
Äh aber die die die Hauptmission wird wird eben so sein, dass ein oder zwei Felder werden länger beobachtet, äh zumindest für Jahre.
Diesen.
Fünfunddreißig mal fünfunddreißig Grad, ja das ist.
Vergleich zu Mondgröße.
Mond ist ein halbes Grad, also 60 Monde in jeder Seitenlänge.
Es ist ordentlich. Ja ja, das ist so ähnlich wie ich denke so ein 80 Millimeter Objektiv für eine kleine Bildkamera, so in der Größe ungefähr, was man da drin sieht.
Ein ordentlich großes Feld,
Wird, weil's ja groß ist, wird es auch mehr relativ helle, helle Sterne beobachten und und die entsprechenden Planeten da drin finden, die Transits von denen. Es wird typischerweise sehr erheblich besser Charakterisierbare Systeme finden, wie wie Kepler gefunden hat.
Die Idee von von Plato ist, dass es wirklich äh die.
Häufigkeit von kleinen Planeten ähm mit Probetalperioden bis zu einigen Monaten zumindest äh recht gut bestimmen kann.
Hat auch eine starke Komponente, die drauf ausgeht, den Stern sehr genau zu bestimmen.
Man kann nämlich durch geringe Helligkeitsschwankungen von den Sternen, zumindest von den helleren Sternen innerhalb von Plato. Da gibt es die sogenannten Astro-, sei's mologische Methode, mit der sehr genau ähm
die Masse und äh und äh die Dichte von dem Stamm bestimmt werden kann. Was dazu führt, dass wir hoffen, dass die die Platussysteme,
Platopplanetensysteme, die ja die ausgemessenen äh Planetensysteme werden,
Eine Sache, die ich vielleicht noch erwähnen sollte, ist bei sowohl bei der Radialgeschwindigkeitsmethode, wie bei der Transitmethode
was wir übermessen ist äh entweder Größe oder Masse vom Planet relativ zum Stirn und oft bei Transit äh Messungen insbesondere wissen wir diese relative Größe sehr genau
aber äh die Präzision der absoluten Planetengröße,
ist letztlich ähm begrenzt durch die absolute Größe vom Stern. Das heißt, es ist sehr wichtig, auch den Stirn äh wirklich genau ähm zu untersuchen und zu charakterisieren.
Sowohl mit Spektroskopie gemacht wird, wie auch eben, wie gesagt, wie dieser Astro-Cysmologischen Methode.
Äh um wirklich genaue Präzisionen zu bekommen vom vom Radius, vom vom Planet. Äh das ist auch sehr wichtig äh für um die Dichte vom Planet äh festzulegen.
Die Dichte geht letztlich. Äh das ist der Radius zum,
zum Kubus hoch drei durch durch die Masse. Zum Beispiel in der wenn der Radius nur zehn Prozent genau bekannt ist von einem Planet.
Weil es hoch drei ist, ist dann die Dichte nur dreißig Prozent genau bekannt, also der Fehler ist erheblich größer, daher ist es sehr wichtig den Radius ziemlich genau
zu messen den absoluten Radius von dem Planet, um auch seine Dichte dann äh dann gut äh zu bestimmen und die Dichte ist so der
Parameter wirklich um einen Planet zu charakterisieren, ob er jetzt eben äh
äh terrestrisches oder von hauptsächlich durch Gas dominiert ist, aber auch um um was es sich handelt. Äh es sind's leichte Elemente oder eher schwerere Elemente. Daher brauchen wir die Dichte ähm
eben relativ genau. Da hoffen wir, dass Plato wirklich ähm einen großen Fortschritt bringt.
Radius ist ja auch immer gemeint der Abstand zum Stern.
Nee nee mit Radio. Jetzt habe ich grad gemeint einen Durchmesser oder die Größe,
Größe vom Planet, der Radius, des des Planetens selber, ja. Na ja, bei bei Sternen sag ich, aus Zeichen der Regel Abstand, Planet, Stern sage ich, Abstand, okay? Ja mit Radis meine ich immer immer das Objekt selber.
Was heißt Plato sucht auch wieder, sucht intensiver, schaut die ganze Zeit auf einen Bereich, der aber sehr groß ist. Ähm Plato, wie ja auch äh das James Web äh Teleskop wird äh glaube ich am Punkt zwei.
Seinen Platz finden, also quasi mit der Erde herumziehen. Ähm da schaut man ja aber eigentlich so übers Jahr verteilt ja immer woanders hin. Wie gelingt es es denn äh da immer diesen.
Ausschnitt im Blick zu behalten.
Ne, das hängt von ab, äh Plato äh kann senkrecht aus der Ebene rausschauen und damit kommt die Sonne nie davor. Äh Felder ausgekriegt. Das wurde,
Es wurde auch bei Capri schon so gemacht,
Kepler ist zwar um die Sonne gezogen, etwas äh vor der Erde entlang, nicht im Lakrosspunkt aber hat letztlich Senkrecht aus der oder mehr oder weniger aus einem steilen Winkel aus unserem Sonnensystem heraus ein Feld beobachten, dann kann man das das umgehendes Problem.
Zwanzig siebenundzwanzig, also hier eine Wikipedia steht noch zwanzig sechsundzwanzig, vermute mal, dass es schon mehrere Male verschoben worden.
Es ist seit einigen Jahren recht stabil
im Moment sind wir dabei, also die einige Komponenten sind auch schon gebaut worden, also nehmen wirklich konkret zu konstruieren, das ganze Designphase ist ist äh fertig
Äh vor wenigen Wochen war auch der sogenannte Critical Design äh Refugee. Das ist also der wirklich
wo wo das Design nochmal wirklich sehr kritisch angeschaut wird und wirklich abgecheckt wird von einem Themen von Experten, ob alles äh wirklich,
gut zusammenpasst äh funktionieren wird.
Stellt man denn da noch was fest, was nicht passt?
Bin da nicht drin, aber die tun gerade nicht drin, aber die tun dann schon äh oft noch Fragen aufwerfen, ne und dann hängt's von ab, ist da irgendein Problem
und kleine Fragen oder oder kleinere Probleme wurden mit Sicherheit einige etliche identifiziert aber es war wohl kein Problem dabei wo das Komitee dann gesagt hat äh,
Das ist ein Showstopper,
Das kann nicht funktionieren und da gibt's auch keine leichte, keine keine hm gute Lösung für, die nicht äh zum Beispiel den Zeitplan auseinanderbringt oder erheblich mehr
mehr Kosten verursachen würde. Das wurde offensichtlich nicht gefunden
es sind sicher noch viele Detailssachen, die noch doch zu checken sind, aber äh wie gesagt, der hat diese passiert diesen sogenannten Critical Design Review.
Womit ihr jetzt in der Phase ist, dass äh wirklich ähm die Teile gebaut werden. Das ist auch was, was ich jetzt persönlich äh gerade
viel mit beschäftigt bin, weil mir machen ja mir eine spanische Beteiligung, wo wir die Elektronik von dem Satellit bauen und äh da haben jetzt im Moment Probleme wegen der Liefersituation von von den äh ganzen Mikrochips.
Aber wir hoffen, dass sich das lösen wird ohne letztlich eine,
ein großes Problem hervorzurufen, äh was eben sein könnte, ne, wenn die Lieferung nicht nicht rechtzeitig kommt, dass der ganze Zeitplan äh ausm Takt gerät und und und der Start verschoben werden müsste, das wäre natürlich äh.
Alles wegen Corona.
Schlecht Corona, letztlich indirekt ist dadran Schuld, ja ja das hat nämlich diese Liefersituation hervorgerufen.
Also mit anderen Worten fünf Jahre vor dem Staat ist das Ding noch nicht komplett fertig gebaut.
Nee, nee, das wird jetzt wirklich angefangen. Äh es gibt ein paar Teile, die wurden vorher schon gebaut, äh an den Kameras äh vor allem aber wirklich systematisch das Ding herzustellen, materiell jetzt herzustellen. Das das geht jetzt grad los. Äh.
Oder ich sitze grad in Gange schon, aber.
Ich hab's vorhin äh erwähnt, es war hier äh Thema in der 99. Ausgabe Cheops. Ist ja eine relativ kleine äh Mission, sehr spezialisiert, welchen Beitrag hat denn äh Krebs bisher schon leisten können? Es ist welche welche Komponente,
Teil füllt das aus.
Da kann ich nicht übermäßig viel erzählen, weil ich in Cheops nicht dabei bin. Also ich habe mich damals am Rand.
Nutzt man nicht die Daten, die da kommen.
Äh aber andere Teams machen das ja so. Ich meine ich ich schaue ich sehe Publikationen. Ich weiß, Cheops ist natürlich äh keine Entdeckungsmission,
Vergleich zu den anderen, also äh Plato, Tess, äh Koro was man Missionen, die neue Systeme entdeckt haben.
Da geht's ums Nachmessen, ne.
Ist kann nur ein einzigen äh Stern oder ein kleines Bildfeld gleichzeitig
aufnehmen und damit nur ein systemtypischerweise anschauen. Äh das ist dazu gedacht, eben Planeten äh bekannte Systeme nachzuverfolgen. Ein Transe, der vorhergesagt wird, äh
wieder zu beobachten, was oft schwierig ist vom Boden aus, weil die Transitz zum Beispiel länger wie äh zwölf Stunden dauern, dann sehen wir keinen kompletten Transit vom Boden, zumindest nicht von einem einzelnen Teleskop.
Da ist Keops interessant. Äh Cheops wurde original auch ähm vorgeschlagen, um Systeme,
durchzuchecken, wo nur Radio Nachweise da sind,
einfach äh sagen wir mal fünf Tage oder so das gleiche System anschauen und schauen, ob da wirklich ein Transit äh ist oder nicht.
Das war eine der Haupt.
Und den dann halt auch vor allem sehr gut vermessen.
Und denen sehr gut vermessen, ja. Ja, also Keops ist auch ein 30 Zentimeter Teleskop, äh das ist doch mit ähnlich wie der originale Koro in in Präzision auch.
Äh es ist eben flexibel einsetzbar und und so wird's jetzt auch gehandhabt. Da gibt's so eine eine Reihe an und dann,
Objekt, die sie vor zu Beginn der Mission schon festgelegt haben, die die beobachtet werden und dann gibt's jetzt aber auch ähm sogenannte Calls, äh wo wo äh Forscher, die interessiert sind ähm,
verwenden können, einen Antrag stellen müssen und wir wollen das jetzt auch machen äh konkret in den nächsten zwei, drei Wochen äh um ein System zu beobachten.
Wo wahrscheinlich ein wir wissen nicht genau was es ist, es ist entweder ein Planet, der sich auflöst.
Oder oder in eine eine dichte Staubwolke, die um den Stern herumkreist und keine ganz klaren Transitz liefert, aber äh,
verwaschene, die ändern sich auch von Zeit zu Zeit etwas. Die haben 200 ziemlich klare Periode, ich glaube 0, acht irgendwas Tage,
aber sie verändern sich. Sie haben auch eine gewisse Farb ähm Farbsignatur, das heißt wir haben in verschiedenen Farben den Transit anschaut, ist er verschieden tief. Wir nennen's im Moment der Everating Planet, also der verdunstende Planet.
Den wollen wir genauer anschauen. Der wurde in Kepler Daten entdeckt vor einigen Jahren,
und immer mal wieder vom Boden beobachtet, damit Kiosk hoffen wir, dass wir dass der mit einem besseren Präzision beobachtet werden kann.
Jedem Instrument steigt sozusagen die Flexibilität bei der äh Beobachtung,
Nächste Runde haben's schon äh angedeutet, wird durch das James Web Teleskop
eingeleitet zu diesem Zeitpunkt als wir hier diese Aufnahme machen, das ist jetzt Ende Februar ist erfolgreich gestartet
sehr erfolgreich gestartet, hat alles super funktioniert. Das Ding ist komplett ausgepackt und zu diesem Zeitpunkt werden gerade die ganzen Instrumente, also die Spiegel erst mal kalibriert,
noch ein paar Monate, aber dann geht's ja los
abgesehen davon, dass man damit in die Tiefen des Universums schauen kann und mal die allerersten Galaxien quasi das First Light sich äh dort der ersten Sterne äh anschaut,
ist ja auch James Web für die Exo Planeten Forschung interessant. Was soll da der Beitrag sein?
Ja, also James Web wird sicher sehr wesentlich sein, nicht für die Entdeckung von neuen Systemen, aber eben für die, was mir die Charakterisierung nennen, eine genaue äh Beobachtung von von bekannten Systemen.
Der Hauptbeitrag von James Web
kommt mit Sicherheit von der sogenannten Transitspektroskopie, die wir schon mal angerissen haben. Äh man beobachtet einen Planet während eines Transits, aber macht
eben äh also eine Zeit, eine Zeitfolge von von Spektren und wir können dann sehen, ein Teil des Lichts von einem,
Stern, das durch den Planet geht, der der vor dem Starneben ist und den verdeckt, das geht durch die Atmosphäre von dem Planeten durch,
und tu dann die die Spektralsignatur von der von der Atmosphäre, die so eine Absorptionsspektrum von der Atmosphäre, von dem Planeten eben äh aufnehmen und das können wir
nachmessen, indem wir Spektrum vergleichen während eines Transitzs und während des Off-Transit-Vor-und nach einem dran zu leben, ne.
Das mit sehr hohem Präzision dieses Spektrum aufnimmt und da wirklich ist es sehr wichtig
viel dicht zu sammeln, äh um die entsprechenden ähm
Signal to Noise äh zu bekommen in diesem Spektrum. Wenn man da eben zwei Spektren haben dann letztlich eins, dass die Durchschnitt ist der der Transitspekt und 1 der Durchschnitte oft Transitspekt und können die voneinander subtrahiert werden und wir sehen dann im Prinzip
die das Spektrum des äh des Absorptionsspektrum der Planetatmosphäre.
Das wurde schon gemacht seit ungefähr 15 Jahren in ein paar die sehr hell sind. Äh
Der der Boot zuerst entdeckt worden ist, aha die zwei null neun vier 5 acht waren's ist nach wie vor ein sehr beliebtes Objekt. Das ist eine sechste Magnetut. Äh Stern.
Und James Web,
hat keinerlei äh Probleme zum Beispiel mit der Spektralsignatur von äh von unserer Erdatmosphäre, die immer wieder störende äh ähm,
Linien äh hervorruft und und degradiert. Äh James Web kann da sehr viel bei ähm liefern,
Es ist eben ein großes Teleskop und extrem präzise und dann äh wo der andere äh gute.
Anwendungspreis ist, dass James Webins Infrarot beobachten kann,
der Vorteil gegenüber über ähm äh Erdgebundenbeobachtung noch erheblich größer ist wie wie im visuellen. Im nahen Infrarot äh
zwar von der Erde viel beobachtet, aber es ist extrem wichtig, dass äh die Atmosphäre sehr, sehr trocken ist
daher ist zum Beispiel Hawaii äh und und und in Chile sind die besten Plätze und und theoretisch auch die Antarktis sind die besten Plätze, wo die Luft sehr, sehr trocken ist und im Moment sehr hoch ist und relativ wenig Absorption im Infraroten hat.
Aber es gibt dann ein paar Bänder, die noch im weiteren Infrarot sind, wo wir auf der Erde überhaupt nichts machen können, weil die grundsätzlich äh die Atmosphäre undurchsichtig ist.
Und das lässt sich eben umgehen mit einer mit einer Mission im All.
Und James Web kann äh eben nahen bis mittleren Infrarot ähm äh eben Beobachtung machen, sowohl Spektren als auch Bilder,
die schlichtweg nicht möglich sind vom Boden. Und das ist wo wirklich James Web wohl wirklich Neuland äh betreten wird.
Vor allem auch in der Beobachtung von Systemen, die eben noch in der Bildung sind, die eben typischerweise diese Temperatur haben, wie wir schon mal erwähnt haben, also Zimmertemperatur mehr oder weniger, äh die die im Infrarot abstrahlen.
Wo dem sowohl Bilder extrem hoch auflösende Bilder gemacht werden können mit James Web, wie auch wie auch Spektren von den äh interessanten ähm.
Das heißt, wir werden vielleicht dann auch mal ein erstes Bild von einem Exoplaneten bekommen.
Also ein,
Planet als Punkt haben wir ja schon äh also zumindest bilden also auflösende Bilder, wo wir den Planet wirklich als Scheibe sehen können äh ist auch James
äh nicht in der Lage dazu, da gibt's andere Projekte, die sind dann im Moment alle auf äh soweit ich weiß auf Eis gelegt.
Da bräuchten wir wirklich Systeme Systeme, wo mehrere Teleskope
jedem gewissen Abstand von Kilometern oder hunderten von Kilometern ein Riesenteleskop praktisch spielen, dass er eine entsprechende optische Auflösung hätte, um auch einen Planeten als Scheibe ähm abzubilden.
Eine ganze Armada von James Webs.
Ja, da gab's das Darwinprojekt, äh das äh Anfang der 2tausender stark äh forciert wurde, äh wo wirklich äh Planeten, das heißt,
wo wir Plane äh Sterne beobachten können und wirklich das Planetensystem dann ziemlich komplett sehen würden als Bild,
Es hatte allerdings auch nicht die Auflösung, die Planeten selber als Scheibe aufzulösen. Da gibt's noch bessere Ideen, die aber im Moment völlig außer Reichweite sind.
Auch nicht so wichtig, äh sehr viel wichtiger ist ja, dass man dass man was drüber weiß. Ähm diese Möglichkeit, den Planeten zumindest dann soweit aufn Pelz zu rücken, dass man mehr über die Zusammensetzung der,
Atmosphäre und damit ja auch mehr über die Zusammensetzung der Planeten als solche weiß, welche.
Also welches Potenzial entwickelt James Web an der Stelle wirklich, was was ist so im äh im Erwartungshorizont, mal jetzt mal die überraschenden Erkenntnisse mal.
Die Überraschenden kann ich ihnen nicht vorhersagen, ja, ja. Ja, ja. Äh.
Erwarte wohl, dass das wohl wichtige Sachen werden sein, dass wir äh
viele also die die Atmosphäre-Charaktisation, die wir schon schon genannt haben, die ist bisher doch immer reichlich oberflächlich. Da werden ein paar Komponenten gefunden.
Und wir können nach wie vor nicht wirklich sagen, was äh was da ist. Äh,
Das andere, wo ich erwarte, dass hoffentlich äh wirklich interessante Ergebnisse kommen, ist eben die Atmosphären von terrestrischen Planeten. Die waren bisher völlig unerreichbar.
Und und James Web sollte uns wirklich die ersten.
Atmosphären, ich hoffe auch einigermaßen detailliert geben von der restlichen Planeten, wo dann auch Planeten vielleicht drunter sind, die mehr oder weniger äh äh habitabel sind.
Also erleben äh leben äh Leben halten äh unterstützen könnten,
Das wird wohl der weitere wirklich große, große äh äh Sprung sein mit James Web ähm
diese diese Klasse vom Planeten, die im Moment wirklich nicht nicht möglich ist äh zu untersuchen, dass dass wir da die ersten ersten Atmosphären bekommen.
Von von erdähnlichen Planeten.
Was wären denn so die interessantesten Erkenntnisse? Also ich meine, man kann jetzt auf alles blicken, man man sammelt jetzt erstmal äh äh Daten.
Äh von Zeit zu Zeit muss man sich ja dann glaube ich auch immer mal wieder fragen, was wollen wir eigentlich wirklich jetzt als nächstes äh verstehen, was sind so äh die entscheidenden Fragen, wo
vielleicht auch viele zukünftige äh Entwicklungen und Erkenntnisse äh dranhängen. Was kann denn so die EXO Planeten Forschung vielleicht,
uns noch einen grundlegenden Erkenntnissen geben wird, außer über die Xo Planeten als solche,
Also was kann man zurückschließen auf unser äh Sonnensystem oder was in äh anderen Bereichen der Kosmologien äh vielleicht einen Einfluss hat.
Ja, ich denke wirklich äh klar zu verstehen, wie unsere Sonnensystem zum einen äh entstanden ist.
Dafür sollten wir andere ähnliche Systeme noch finden und und auch auch analysieren. Äh die.
Schon welche gefunden, also die.
Wir haben wie gesagt Jupiter haben wir bisher gefunden, ähnliche Jubiter vielleicht auch mal uns Saturn äh Äquivalent, aber aber weitere noch nicht. Äh,
Und ich denke dann äh wirklich die wesentliche Frage, die Exce Planeten auch auch stark motiviert ist eben, die das Vorhandensein von Leben im Universum.
Ist es wirklich was? Sind wir wirklich eine große Ausnahme hier oder ist es doch eher wahrscheinlich, dass es dass es viele Sterne gibt, wo wo eben Planeten sind, die leben äh unterstützen könnten.
Weiter weg dann eben die Frage auch äh hochentwickeltes Leben oder nicht,
wie intelligentes Leben natürlich, wo dann auch einen gewissen Überlapp haben mit den City-Projekten, die wirklich versuchen direkt äh extra technische Intelligenzen zu finden und das praktisch Abkürzen dann diesen Weg.
Dass es im Moment wohl auch die die Hauptmotivation äh äh für für viele der der Projekte die die laufen.
Dass wir da einen Weg finden, die die Planeten genauer zu charakterisieren, zum Beispiel zu sehen, ob,
äh wirklich äh Gase sind, die darauf hinweisen, am Beispiel Sauerstoff oder Ozon, dass da wohl biologische Prozesse auf diesem Planeten äh im Gange sind.
Eben die Frage, sind wir allein im Universum? Sind wir relativ häufig.
Sind wohl sehr grundlegende Fragen, die auch schon vor der Entdeckung von Planeten äh äh diskutiert worden sind.
Vielleicht schon die griechischen Philosophen haben sich schon mit denen beschäftigt, mit dieser Frage äh die aber nach wie vor nicht gelöst ist. Äh.
Das ist, wo ich denke, diese Forschung kann uns wirklich äh die.
Gute Hinweise geben zumindest. Es ist sehr graduell, es baut aufeinander auf. Äh.
Was vorhin schon mal angerissen worden ist. Vielleicht können wir eines Tages wirklich andere Planeten ähnliche Karten, ähnliche Karten sehen davon und wirklich sehen, ob die zum Beispiel äh äh im Winter,
weiß sind in einem Pool und im Sommer grün und das sind Wälder dann wahrscheinlich da das vielleicht in der Entfernung Zukunft durchaus möglich.
Letztlich die Planeten sind, der Bestandteile im Universum, mit dem wir uns am besten auch auskennen oder wir leben auf einem.
Und daher denke ich auch, dass es wirklich wichtig ist äh zu sehen, tun diese Erden woanders existieren. Wie könnten sie sein? Es regt auch die Fantasieen äh oft äh wie wie dieser Planeten aussehen könnten.
Was was gibt es an an Bandbreite in der Natur wirklich was da produziert werden könnte.
Weißt äh, wer's richtig mitbekommen habe, es gibt aber eigentlich alles, was wir bisher gesehen haben, ist erstmal nicht unbedingt jetzt genauso wie unser Sonnensystem.
Gebaut. Das mag einfach sein, dass wir noch zu wenig angeschaut haben. Es könnte aber trotzdem eben sein, dass es eben einfach bedeutet, dass hier doch irgendwas,
Komisch gelaufen ist, sind wir doch in irgendeiner Form so ein Zufallsprodukt äh Produkt sind. Denkst du darüber?
Ja, es gibt eben die Theorie, dass unsere Sonnensystem so ist, wie es ist, weil äh in der Frühzeit des Sonnensystems ein weiterer Stern relativ nah an unserer Protoson vorbeiging,
und da entsprechend äh die die ähm Autoplanetare, Scheibe äh etwas gestört hat. Äh ist eine Theorie,
äh und daher wär's interessant natürlich zu sehen, ob diese Theorie vielleicht richtig ist oder nicht. Äh wenn die Theorie stimmt, wären wir relativ selten,
Na ja, weil diese diese nahen Vorbeigänge relativ selten eben nur nur vorkommen würden. Wenn die Theorie falsch ist, dann sollten wir euch eher relativ häufig sein, unsere Sonnensysteme.
Wie nah sind wir noch dran an dieser Erkenntnis? Also wie wie viel mehr.
Beobachten, also.
Ja äh ich denke wir um unsere Sonnensysteme wirklich besser zu charakterisieren brauchen wir,
zum großen Teil auch mehr Zeit schlichtwegs, weil die die Perioden von einem Jupiter ist elf Jahre von Saturn und ich richtig pensiblen 20 Jahre.
Noch länger äh etliche Jahrzehnte bis über über 100 Jahre. Äh,
mit Radialgeschwindigkeiten, was dafür die geeignetste Methode ist im Moment, äh brauche ich mir dann eben auch etliche Jahrzehnte, um da wirklich eine komplette Periode äh zu beobachten.
Daher kommen diese Systeme mit der Zeit langsam rein. Äh daher gibt's jetzt auch die ersten mehr oder weniger Jupiter ähnlichen äh Planeten um um andere eine Sterne, die bekannt sind.
Ist es denn vorstellbar, dass man auch nur aus einem einzigen Transit, den man beobachtet, schon äh Rückschlüsse äh ziehen kann, dass man sich mal so sicher ist, dass das auch wirklich einer ist?
Nee, nee äh hm.
Das wäre eine schöne Abkürzung.
Es wäre eine schöne Abkürzung bei Kepler wurde das versucht. Die Kepler-Mission wurde eigentlich gestartet mit der mit der Motivation, dass äh.
So was wie unsere Erde, um eine Sonne gefunden wird. Deshalb wurde die vier Jahre lang äh sollte die laufen, womit eine Erde, wo man die Sonne, wenn die richtig ausgerichtet ist, äh eben vier, drei bis vier Transitz äh hervorruft und,
dem Sinne ist, Käpplei gescheitert, äh obwohl's die wichtigste Mission war, die am meisten bisher geliefert hat, aber im Sinne des der Originalmotivation, mit der damals die Anträge geschrieben wurden in den 90ern noch,
äh ist Kepler gescheitert, dass es wirklich kein echtes äh zweites äh Sonnensystem gefunden hat. Keine zweite Erde, Erde Nummer zwei.
War das vielleicht nur das Ziel, weil man das am besten finanziert bekommt.
Das können liegt immer bisschen dahinter, dass diese diese Anträge werden so geschrieben, dass da was Interessantes ist, äh das nicht realistisch ist und auch gleichzeitig eben äh ähm,
attraktiv ist. Das ist klar, äh wenn Sie wussten ja damals auch nicht einmal, welche Planeten häufig sind und welche nicht, weil Kepler wurde ursprünglich noch vor der Entdeckung der ersten Planeten äh vorgeschlagen, unter anderem Namen.
Äh daher kommen da sehr viele heraus bei solchen Missionen, dass wir das nicht vorher gesehen ist.
Wichtig ist vielleicht, äh um wirklich zu sehen, ob's andere Systeme gibt wie unsere. Wer eine weitere Missionie damals bei die sogenannte Darwin-Mission, die die dann wieder
eingestellt wurde in den 2tausendern
wo eben mehrere Teleskope zusammen versuchen hochauflösende Bilder zu machen. Da kann man dann wirklich einen Planetensystem, das war die Idee von da, wenn wirklich die nächsten,
Sterne, also äh vom absoluten Abstand zu uns die allernächsten Sterne innerhalb von 1 Lichtjahren oder 15 Lichtjahren wirklich systematisch zu beobachten und da Bilder aufzunehmen. Und wirklich zu sehen, ob
die äh Planetensysteme haben, die mehr oder weniger unseren entsprechen.
Das wäre also eine Methode, wo es aber dann letztlich äh waren es technische Probleme oder oder Unabwägbarkeiten äh Risiken.
Mehrere sehr große ähm Teleskope im Aal zusammenzustarten und dass die zusammen äh mit interfermetrie eben wirklich zusammenarbeiten.
Das war zu teuer und zu zu risikoreich, da heißt diese Mission äh ähm vor zehn Jahren ungefähr eingestellt worden, der die Arbeiten dazu. Aber das wäre eine Lösung, die dazu,
führt hätte wohl, dass dass wir wirklich sehen könnten die nächsten Sterne haben so und so viel Planeten.
Bräuchte man sozusagen eine finanzierbare Mission, die sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr lange läuft, ähm wenn man sich das so jetzt in den,
Orbitalen Projekten äh anschaut, geht ja der Trend hin zu, na ja, wir bauen halt dasselbe Ding äh x mal, dann wird das irgendwie schön billig ähm,
hauen dafür aber auch regelmäßig neue raus. So eine Dauerbestückung.
Ja, da könnte schon vielleicht mal Ideen geben äh vielleicht kleinere Teleskope zu bauen, ja in Serie, die dann wirklich äh äh zusammenarbeiten könnten.
Alte ersetzen und sozusagen dieselbe Beobachtung ja immer immer.
Ja, ja oder eben mit interfermetrie wirklich zusammenarbeiten. Da könnte's auch sein, dass es irgendwann mal vielleicht gute Fortschritte gibt äh in in das ist hauptsächlich Sachen mit Steuer- und Regeltechnik. Äh zwischen diesen äh Instrumenten.
Dass dass es da Fortschritte gibt äh.
Ja ja, aber im Moment, wie gesagt, ist keine keine Mission in der Richtung gestartet, aber sicher, es gibt neue Generationen an Forschern auch, die neue Ideen bringen und und das ist natürlich das Wichtige, dass das immer wieder da.
Eben kommen für weitere Missionen. Vielleicht kommen aber auch aus unerwarteten Richtungen äh äh Ideen, wo wir jetzt gar nicht dran denken, weil so irgendwelche exotischen äh Entdeckungsmethoden.
Das das können wir wirklich nicht nicht vorhersehen im Moment, ja.
Jetzt können wir sie erstmal auf die Ergebnisse von James Web ähm freuen, das äh geht ja dann so in einem halben Jahr los und dann,
Nochmal äh schauen, was passiert. Plätze zum Schluss, mich würde ja nochmal interessieren, was man
noch so äh bisher entdeckt hat, was vielleicht auch jetzt nicht unbedingt zu dem Stall entspricht. Also auf der einen Seite sucht man etwas, was so ist wie unser Sonnensystem, weil das soll uns natürlich irgendwie Erkenntnisse geben. Andererseits hat man viel anderes äh gefunden.
Wie weird sind denn die ganzen Planetensysteme, die man so bisher gefunden hat? Was sind denn da so die absurdesten Konstellationen,
man so entdeckt hat und du hast ja vorhin auch schon diese.
Genau das.
Wahrscheinlich auch in diese Kategorie.
Genau das äh ist die eine Sache, die ihr sicher noch noch äh besprechen sollten, weil die
ähm Planeten, äh wie ich habe schon gesagt, unser erstes äh Beobachtungsprojekt äh neunzehn
93 das gestartet wurde, hat so einen Planeten versucht nachzuweisen, um einen Doppelstern und äh Planeten sind vielleicht im Moment die exotischen Planeten, die die bekannt sind.
Wenn Sie Stattreg kennen, äh haben Sie vielleicht vom Planet Tattooin äh.
Star Wars.
Star Wars, ja. Äh Star Wars. Äh wo eben ein Planet ist, der der zwei Sonnen hat, äh die ähm
eine geht auf, die andere geht unter, das Licht ist verschieden äh äh die die Bedingungen ändern sich die ganze Zeit und diesen Planeten waren eigentlich eher,
ist immer ein sehr sehr hypothetisch und die meisten haben wohl schon gedacht, dass es äh mhm dass es Science-Fiction ist eben, ne. Äh,
Der erste von diesen äh Planeten wurde gefunden äh in Daten der der Kepler-Mission.
Weil solche Planeten, wenn wenn die um den um den Doppelstand gehen und Transitz hervorrufen, dann äh haben die sehr sehr klare äh äh Signale,
Transits äh.
Sie nicht genau periodisch, weil der weil der Doppelstand selber sich sich eben ähm auch bewegt und äh sind Semiperiodisch, wenn der Planet vor dem
Sternsystem vorbeigeht, Harz dran sind, aber wann Hartz dran sitzt, aber wann die genau auftauchen, hängt von der von der Phase oder von der Periode von der Position, von einem Doppelstand eben ab.
Wenn man.
Überhaupt noch eine normale Ägyptik, wenn da so zwei Sterne sind, also kann man sich das so vorstellen.
Uns mal die alle in der gleichen Ebene vorstellen, sowohl die Bahnebene vom Stern wie die Bahnebene vom,
Planet um den äh um den Schwerpunkt des der,
äh für um Transitz zu haben. Es es gibt Exoten, es könnte exotischere Konfigurationen geben, wo die beiden Bahnebenen geneigt sind gegenüber und leicht geneigt sind sie auch. Äh die, wo bisher gefunden worden sind.
Noch nicht bekannt ist, ist, ob's wirklich steil zwischeneinander geneigt äh hat.
Aber gut, äh es wurden die ersten gefunden äh vor,
acht, 9 Jahren ungefähr, wo eben ein Planet, um um einen Doppelstand geht, der Doppelstand ist relativ eng zueinander, die haben also Perioden von äh,
Wie war's? Ähm.
Äh mehr etwas sieben Tage bis ungefähr 50 Tage haben die die Sternelperperioden und die Planeten haben relativ große Perioden äh für Transitsysteme jedenfalls. Ein paar.
Sterne untereinander, dass sie sozusagen untereinander äh sich quasi einmal die Plätze austauschen. Aha.
Ja sieben Tage äh Periode vom Sturm, mindestens sieben Tage, das ist.
Okay und die und die Planeten kreisen dann quasi um diesen gemeinsamen Schwerpunkt.
Reisen, um den gemeinsamen, die brauchen ungefähr eine Periode, die mindestens drei, vier Mal länger ist wie wie wie der Stern um sich selbst
wenn die zu nahe in dem Stirn sind, haben die nämlich keine stabilen Obits äh und würden in den Sternen entweder stutzen oder oder oder äh raus äh katapultiert werden aus dem System.
Äh jedenfalls wurden diese Systeme gefunden vor sieben, acht Jahren. Die ersten in der Kepler-Mission ähm und war wirklich unerwartet.
Wobei wir haben natürlich die schon vor langer Zeit beobachtet, aber konnten auch versucht zu finden, aber konnten auch nicht wirklich sagen, ob das jetzt wirklich äh ob's die gibt oder nicht war. Daher wäre toll, dass dass die gefunden wurden.
Mittlerweile gibt's aber bisher.
Fast alle von von Capler äh gibt's ungefähr 7zehn so denke ich 17 Systeme von der Sorte. Äh Tes hat jetzt auch zwei Stück gefunden.
Äh und die haben alle gewisse Eigenschaften, wo man noch nicht ganz sicher ist, wieso das sind alles Planeten, die mittlere Größe haben.
Die Sterne aus irgendeinem Grund, wo es gibt's Theorien dazu. Ich denke, da setzt zu weiter reinzugehen. Die Sterne haben mindestens eine Orbit-Periode von 7 Tagen. Äh das ist reine Beobachtung bisher.
Von den 15 bis 17 Systemen, die bekannt sind. Hat wahrscheinlich was mit der Entstehungsgeschichte zu tun. Das das äh Sternsysteme, die,
untereinander mit schneller umeinander sich umkreisen. Es sind eigentlich häufiger und leichter zu beobachten, aber da wurden bisher keine Planeten drum ge.
Ist denn äh die Optik, die man so äh jetzt bei Star Wars äh von Tatoin ähm bekommen hat, könnte man sich das dann auch so vorstellen, wenn es jetzt wirklich mal so ein habitabler äh oder halbwegs habitabler Planet wäre. Also da hat man so so zwei Sonnenuntergänge.
Ja ja, man hätte zwei Sonnenuntergänge,
die werden immer relativ nah beieinander. Also die beiden äh von gesehen vom vom Planet aus äh,
werden die Sterne nie weiter wie ich denke so fünfundzwanzig, 30 Grad auseinander.
Aber der eine würde vor dem anderen untergehen und wenn das verschiedene Typen sind, würde sich dann auch ziemlich die die Farbe ändern, die die wir äh die wir in der Umgebung hätten
Die könnten durchaus auch äh Leben unterstützen, also da gibt's schon Studien dazu. Äh wenn der Abstand von dem von dem ähm,
Stammsystem groß genug ist, äh macht es keinen großen Unterschied, ob da jetzt äh ein Stern untergegangen ist oder beide,
weil es relativ kurze Zeiträume sind wir haben auch Tag und Nacht und nachts äh bleibt die Temperatur innerhalb von zehn, fünfzehn Grad von der Tagestemperatur typischerweise. Daher macht es
relativ wenig aus. Also sie könnten durchaus auch auch äh leben neben Beherbergen diese Systeme. Daher,
durchaus realistisch, dass es dass es vielleicht solche solche Systeme gibt und da auch Leben drauf ist. Also Tattoos können durchaus möglich sein.
Das war meine Perspektive.
Bei der Plator-Mission hoffen wir übrigens, dass dass wir von diesen sekundären Systemen vielleicht dreißig, 40, 50 finden.
Doppelsternsysteme an sich halt auch nicht selten sind.
Die sind ziemlich häufig, also knapp die Hälfte der Sterne ist ist in irgendeiner Art ein Doppelstern, wo viele allerdings sehr weit entfernt es sind von Hunderten und Tausenden von ostronomischen Einheiten. Äh.
Zum Schluss noch mal so die die aktuelle Erkenntnis. Wie viel Planet gibt's da draußen? Wovon muss man jetzt ausgehen? Wie selbstverständlich, wie normal ist das?
Ja ganz grob ähm ähm wir wissen, dass ungefähr die Hälfte der der Sterne Planeten von irgendeiner Sorte haben. Also es ist ein extrem häufig. Äh wahrscheinlich haben die meisten Sterne.
Meine ich jetzt normalem Hauptsequenzsterne. Äh dass die Planeten haben. Das ist echt.
Einfach ergibt aus daraus wie einen Stern entsteht. Es bleibt immer was übrig und das.
Bildet sich diese diese Staubwolke erst, die sich dann abflacht
Äh und es gibt da eine Scheibe und im Zentrum bildet sich der Stern und weiter außen bleibt Material übrig und das muss irgendwas machen früher oder später zieht sich das zusammen und es gibt Planeten, das.
Hat er nur die Hälfte wahrscheinlich planiert.
Also Hälfte ist dieser Planeten, die wir im Moment entdecken können eben, ne? Das sind die etwas größeren Planeten, die in relativ kurzen Umlaufbahnen sind typischerweise. Da sind wir sicher.
So etwas findet sich, okay, so was findet sich schon mal bei der Hälfte und die andere Hälfte hat wahrscheinlich auch irgendwas, da müssen wir blo.
Hat wahrscheinlich auch übers, das können wir unsere Sonnensysteme sein, wie unser Sonnensystem oder es könnte auch theoretisch sein, dass da eben keine Planeten sind, aber es ist eine Minderheit auf jeden Fall.
Daher Planeten sind extrem häufig. Es gibt mit Sicherheit erheblich mehr Planeten wie wie Sterne. Eine Sache, wo auch jetzt die ersten Erkenntnisse übrigens kommen, ist äh Mohnthe um Planeten.
Da gibt's zwei Kandidaten im Moment von sehr großen Monden um relativ massive Planeten,
äh die über Transitz in der Kepler-Mission ähm als Kandidaten eben entdeckt worden sind äh wo auch,
vielleicht, dass James Web mal nachhelfen könnte, so
zu einem Transit weiter nachzubeobachten. Wir können vorausrechnen, wann die Transits geschehen in diesem System und das sollte das dann mal anschauen mit sehr hoher Präzision, bessere Präzision noch wie Kepler.
Mir da wirklich äh was sehen, was wir sehen würden, wäre das erst der Mond oder erst der Planet vor dem Stamm vorbeigeht und dann der der andere Körper,
Damit hätten wir praktisch zwei überlagerte Transitz, einem Hormon, einem vom Planeten, die verschiedenen tief sind und es gibt eine gewisse gewisse ähm.
Äh Figur dann, ne, die sich beim nächsten dran sind, wieder anders aussehen würde, also in eine eine umlaufbaren Funkplanet später einen anderen.
Das könnte schon nachgewiesen werden für relativ massive äh Mond ist das realistisch.
Und das ist, ich meine, wenn man jetzt auch mal wieder hochrechnet, mit was es bei uns normal, was muss eigentlich auch äh sonst normal sein? Mone gibt's allein in unserem Sundsystem. Also man entdeckt ja äh am laufenden Meter nochmal neue.
Ja, es letztlich keine große Überraschung, wenn Monde gefunden werden und im Moment eher die Monde, die gefunden werden könnten, sind sehr massive, wie es in unserem Sonnensystem eben nicht,
Der eine war zweieinhalb Adradien groß. Also der Mond ist zweieinhalb Adradien und der Planet äh in den Jupiter mäßiger.
Eine Klasse, die wir eben vielleicht mal jetzt finden können, weil wir dafür die Empfindlichkeit haben, auch wenn die vielleicht insgesamt gesehen eher exotisch ist.
Hans. Jetzt haben wir's eigentlich erstmal, wa.
Mhm, gut, ja, ja, ja. Ja, ja.
Schönes Update, vielen Dank. Ähm ist auf jeden Fall eine Menge los äh am Himmel. Kann man sagen.
Dass das sicherlich, ja ja, es ist nach wie vor ein ein Feld, das äh sich schnell weiterentwickelt, äh wo nach wie vor.
Dein Tipp? Gibt's noch ein haben wir noch einen neunten Planeten, den wir hier äh finden können.
Ja, den gibt's ziemlich wahrscheinlich, das das große Problem ist und und da sieht man, wie schwierig Planeten ist zum Teil. Wahrscheinlich hat's einen 9ten Planeten, aber wir sind nicht in der Lage, den genau festzustellen, wo er ist, weil der eben,
Der ist so brutal weit auch nicht in Fern wahrscheinlich, so ungefähr hundert astronomische Einheiten oder so.
Aber der äh und ist wahrscheinlich auch relativ groß, aber aber die da so dunkel, dass dass der bisher nicht gefunden worden ist. Äh,
extremer Fall von einem Planet, der das sehr, sehr schwer äh entdeckbar ist und das sieht man irgendwie, wie welche riesigen Unterschiede es gibt. Es ist leicht, diese Hot Tubes um andere Sterne mittlerweile.
Zu sehen, selbst Amateure haben Transitbeobachtungen da mittlerweile in großer Menge geliefert und ein,
großen Planeten in unserem Sonnensystem, haben bisher selbst die besten Instrumente nicht wirklich finden können.
Aber du hältst sie die These für durchaus wahrscheinlich.
Ja ich bin da zwar kein Experte auf diesem Thema, aber vorabweichungen der der Orbits von äh Neptun und Pluto äh und auch von der vorhanden von von der Ausrichtung der der Ort Cloud, der der Kometen im ähm,
im Ort klaut, äh ist es wohl sehr wahrscheinlich ziemlich sicher, dass es noch ein weiteres massives Objekt äh weiter außen gibt.
Es gibt noch viel zu entdecken. Hans, vielen, vielen Dank.
So ist es äh.
Die Ausführung.
Danke Team für die Gelegenheit hier aus äh über darüber äh erzählen zu können.
Gerne. Dafür ist das Format äh gedacht.
Noch einen schönen Aufenthalt in Teneriffa. Ja ja.
Weitere Aufnahmen werden jetzt hier folgen auf dieser Reise äh und was das ist, das äh werdet ihr dann sehen. Da verrate ich jetzt erstmal noch nicht. Ja und äh vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und bis dahin sage ich tschüss und bis bald.